- [Instructor] What we're going to do
using our powers of calculus
is find the area of this yellow region
and if at any point you get inspired,
I always encourage you to pause the video
and try to work through it on your own.
So, the key here is you
might recognize hey,
this is an area between curves.
A definite integral might be useful,
so I'll just set up the
definite integral sign
and so, first we're gonna
think about what are left
and right boundaries of our region?
Well, it looks like the left boundary
is where the two graphs
intersect right over here
and the right boundary
is where they intersect right over there.
Well, what is this point of intersection?
It looks like it is
negative one, negative two.
We can verify that.
In this red curve, if X is negative one,
let's see, you square that,
you'll get one minus three.
You do indeed get Y is
equal to negative two
and in this blue function
was X is equal to negative one,
you get one minus four plus one.
Once again, you do indeed get
Y is equal to negative two
and the same thing is true
when X is equal to one.
One minus three, negative two,
one minus four plus one, negative two.
So, our bounds are
indeed, we're going from X
equals negative one to
X equals positive one
and now let's think about
our upper and lower bounds.
Over that interval this blue graph
is our upper bound
and so, we would subtract the lower bound
from the upper bound,
so we would have X to the fourth,
minus four X squared plus one
and from that we will subtract X squared
minus three DX
and in many other videos we have talked
about why you do this,
why this makes sense to just subtract
the lower graph from the upper graph
when you're finding the area between them
but now we just have to
evaluate this definite integral,
so let's just get down to business.
Alright, so we have the integral
from negative one to one,
and so, we have X to the
fourth, X to the fourth,
and now we have minus four X squared
and then when you distribute
this negative sign,
you're gonna subtract another X squared,
so you're gonna have minus five X squared
and then you have plus one
and then you're gonna
subtract a negative three,
so it's gonna be one plus three,
so it's gonna be plus four DX,
DX and just to be clear
I should put parentheses right over there
because it's really the
DX is being multiplied
by this entire expression
and so, let's see, let's find
the antiderivative of this.
This should be pretty straightforward.
We're just gonna use
the reverse power rule
multiple times, so this is
going to be the antiderivative
of X to the fourth is X
to the fifth over five.
We just incremented the exponent
and divided by that incremented exponent,
minus, same idea here,
five X to the third over three
plus four X
and then we are going to evaluate it
at one and then subtract from that
and evaluate it at negative one.
So, let's first evaluate it at one.
We're gonna get 1/5
minus 5/3 plus four
and now let us evaluate
it at negative one,
so minus, let's see, if
this is negative one,
we get a negative 1/5, negative 1/5
and this is gonna be plus 5/3,
plus 5/3 and then this is
going to be minus four,
minus four but then when you distribute
the negative sign, we're
going to distribute this
over all of these terms,
and so this is going to be,
if we make this positive,
this will be positive,
this one will be negative
and then this one will be positive,
so you have 1/5 plus 1/5
which is going to be 2/5, that and that,
and then minus 5/3, minus 5/3,
so minus 10 over three
and then four plus four,
so plus eight
and so, we just need to simplify this.
This is going to be, let's see,
it's going to be eight
and then if I write, so plus,
I'm gonna write these two
with a denominator of 15
'cause that's the common
denominator of three and five.
Let's see, 2/5 is 16/15,
yeah, that's right,
five times three is 15.
Two times three is six
and then 10/3, let's see, if we multiply
the denominator times fives,
we have to multiply the
numerator times five,
so this is going to be 50/15
and so, what's 6/15 minus 50/15?
So, this is going to be equal to eight
minus six minus 50 is minus 44,
minus 44 over 15
and so what is 44 over 15?
44 over 15 is equal to two and 14/15,
so that's really what we're subtracting.
We're gonna subtract two and 14/15,
so if you subtract two from this
you would get six minus 14 over 15
'cause we still have to subtract the 14/15
and then six minus 14/15
is going to be equal to five and 1/15.
So, just like that, we were indeed
able to figure out this area.